الان الى حرب روسيا في اوكرانيا فقد صرح
مدير الاستخبارات العسكريه الاوكرانيه بان
شن روسيا هجوما انطلاقا من اراضي
بيلاروسيا ليس مستبعدا لكنه يبقى احتمالا
ضعيفا حسب تعبيره من جهتها نفت موسكو ذلك
وقالت ان مهمه الاتحاد العسكري بين روسيا
وبيلاروسيا هي صدو اي عدوان المحتمل على
اراضي بيلاروسيا ميدانيه الاوكرانيه
على الجانب الاخر قال السلطات ودونيس
كالمواليه
على احياء مدينه ومقاطعه دنيا
كيف مراسل جزيره تامر الجديد
نعم سفيان سبعه قتلى حتى الان في هذا
الهجوم الذي نفذ على وسط مدينه خرسون جنوب
البلاد وهناك اكثر من 58 جريحا 17 منهم في
حاله خطره السلطات المحليه تقول ان هذا
الهجوم تقصد ايقاع اكبر قدر من قتلى في
المدنيين وذلك انه وقع في مركز المدينه في
مكان كان يتجمع فيه بعض هذه الحصول على
بعض المساعدات وكانوا يصفون في ارتال
وحينها وقع القصف وهذا ما يبرر كما قالت
مره اخرى ان ان الغرض من الهجوم هو ترويع
الناس وايضا احداث اكبر عدد ممكن من
القتلى ايضا افاده ناشطون في المدينه من
تجده على تجديد القسم مره اخرى باستخدام
المدافع همم
على همم
الرئيس الاوكراني قال ان هذه الحادث يهدف
الى ترويع الاوكرانيين في عشيه عيد
الميلاد
ليه المسيحيين كما كذلك كان هناك هجوم في
منطقه الشرقيه استهدف وعدده مناطق على طول
خط الجبهه وايضا حتى على المناطق المدنيه
في كره خوفا اضافه الى قصف على بعض المدن
والمبيدات التابعه
لمقاطعه حاكم المقاطعه بابلو كورنينجو قال
في وقت سابق ان ااه مدنيين قتل وجرح اربعه
اخرون في قصف سابقا للقوات الروسيه
المعارك في مدينه التي تعد اكثر مع
المناطق سخونه بين الجانبين ما تزال
مستمره جيش الاوكراني اليوم وغرفه
العمليات مشتركه المشتركه بثت صورا لجثث
قتلاروس لم تحدد متى تم تصوير هذا المقطع
لكنها تظهر عدد كبيرا من القتلى الروس في
تلك المدينه في مدينه باخمه وهي قد اعلنت
في وقت سابقا من المدينه خاليه من اي وجود
العصر الروسيه اخيرا
كان هناك ايضا عمل عسكري من قبل قوات ارض
الاوكرانيه في الجبهه الشماليه في مقاطعه
الوهاسك حاكم مقاطعه الهاسكي الاوكراني في
تصريح سابق له اليوم ان الحكومه
الانفصاليه او ان الاداره الانفصاليه في
مدينه الصفوفا التي تشن على محيط القوات
الاوكرانيه هجوما منذ نحو شهرين قد غادرت
الى مناطق السيطره الانفصاليين داخل
المقاطعه من ربما ينذر باقترابي دخوله هذه
المدينه وكان سرغي نفسه اكثر من مناسبه ان
بضع كيلومترات فقط تفصل الجيش الاوكرانيه
عن مركز المدينه ولكن ما يحولون تقدم اكثر
باتجاه ووجود اهداف الالغام التي زرعتها
القوات الانفصاليه وايضا الجيش الروسي
ختاما مدينتي كل مقاطعه وايضا تعرضته لقص
بعض البلدات فيها الى قصف ادى الى بعض
الاضافيه همم مشاهده المباراه التحتيه
وبعض منازل المناديين
[موسيقى]
شلت القوات الروسيه خلال الساعات الماضيه
10 غارات جويه استهدفت البنيه التحتيه
المدنيه في منطقه دونيت كما اطلق العدو 65
صاروخا على مدينه خرسون نتجت عنها اضرار
في منشات مدنيه واصابات بين المدنيين وصدت
وحدات من قوات الدفاع الاوكرانيه هجمات
المحتلين باتجاه اندريفكا في منطقه لوجان
وهجمات باتجاه امبو نيفيا وباخموت وفيديان
ومارينكا في منطقه دنياك
ابقى معنا عمر الحاجه اذهب الى رانيا
دريدي في موسكو رانيا يعني فتح ربما
الجبهه جديده الشمالا من قبل روسيا هذا
الامر غير وارد لعل هذا ما نفهمه من
التصريحات الاخيره الروسيه بشان الاتحاد
العسكري مع بيلاروسيا
او وزاره الخارجيه الروسيه اليوم جدد
تاكيدها انه لا توجد اي خطط لدى موسكو
بفتح جبهه من الجانب البيريروسي نحو
اوكرانيا بل على العكس اشارت مجددا ان ااه
يعني نحن نعلم ان روسيا وبالروسيا تجمع
لهما
تحالفات كبيره هناك دوله الاتحاد التي
تجمع كل البلدين هناك علاقات استراتيجيه
تجمع من موسكو على الصعيد الاقتصاديه على
الصعيد الطاقه وايضا على الصعيد العسكري
تم تشكيل قوات اقليميه مشتركه تم الاعلان
عن ذلك في شهر اكتوبر الماضي الجانب
الروسي اعلن ان هناك نظام جوي موحد بات
يخدم الى البلدين للدفاع عن اراضي كل من
روسيا بلا روسيا تم تزويد مين بانظمه دفاع
جوي متطوره وحديثه من طراز اس 4 الى جانب
تزويد الانس بمنظمات صواريخ اسكندر كل ذلك
بحسب الج ارقصي هدفه هو صد اي عدوان او
هجوم محتمل على الاراضي البيلاروسيه
بالطبع سفيان كل ذلك هو اشاره بالدرجه
الاولى الى همم حلف الناتو الى اقتراب
البنيه التحتيه لحلفي شمال الاطلسي من
حدود روسيا الغربيه من الحدود البيلاروسيا
وروسيا تنكر بلؤكد ذلك في العديد من
المناسبات على اللسان وزاره الدفاع
الخارجيه ان ذلك يشكل تهديدا امنيا مباشره
لامن كل من روسيا وبالتالي ايضا لامني
بلال روسيا وعليه فان كل هذه الخطوات الى
جانب التدريبات العسكريه التي تجري على
الارض في بلا روسيا بشكل منتظم بين الفينه
والاخرى هدفه بالفعل هو بالرسائل مواجهه
لحلف الجمال الاطلسي ما افادها ان روسيا
مستعد ثاني لاي تطور خطير قد ينتج عن اي
تحركات من قبل
الصيف اما فيما يتعلق بالعمليه العسكريه
الروسيه على الارض هي فالرئيسه
البيلاروسيه لوكسندر لوكاسانكا اكد في
العديد من المناسبات انه لا توجد خطط
لدميز كليب التدخل عسكريا في هذا النظام
فضلا عن ذلك اليوم الخارجيه الروسيه اكدت
مجددا على هذه الجزئيه همم لو تحدثنا عن
تطورات الاوضاع على الارض في اوكرانيا
اليوم وزاره الدفاع الروسيه اكدت ان اا
يعني القوات المسلحه الروسيه مستمره في
عملياتها العسكريه على الارض خلال الساعات
الاربعه والعشرين الماضيه قضت على نحو 200
عسكري اوكراني في مناطق متفرقه يعني وجلهم
في همم يمكن القول في مناطق كادانيا
الى ذلك ولكن حسب وزاره الدفاع الروسيه
فان عمليات هجوميه حاليا تقوم القوات
المسلحه الروسيه بشانها على محور دانيسك
وهناك تدور معارك على ما بيبدوا ظاهر
انطلاقه من التصريحات التي تصلنا حتى هذه
اللحظه
ولوقوف على تفاصيل هذه العمليه واخر
المعطيات لنستمع لما قاله الناطق باسم
وزاره الدفاع الروسيه اذا كان في هذا
الشان
يابورد
كوبيان
واكثر من 40 اخرين في جمهوريه تونس كما
قمنا بتصفيه نحو 60 من العسكريين
الاوكرانيين والمرتزقه الاجانب خلال
العمليات الهجوميه في محور الجنس اما في
محور التونسي الجنوبي فتم القضاء على اكثر
من اربعين عسكريا اوكرانيا السلاح الجويه
الروسي واسقط في مقاطعه مقاتله اوكرانيا
وثلاثه من وحيات كما تم اسقاطه مسيره
اوكرانيه خلال اليوم الماضي في مناطق
متفرقه
شكرا جزيلا اذن لكما رانيا الدريدي من
موسكو وعمر الحاج شكرا لكما